left-hander jesus lusaro on the mound
for the oakland a's two and two with a
4.23 era in eight games six starts 38 in
the third innings 39 hits 13 walks 38
strikeouts league adding 267. george
springer will lead things off for the
astros batting 233 2-1 that's driven
pretty well and pretty deep to
left-center field and you can't kiss
that one goodbye
a lead-off home run for george springer
his second of the year and the astros
jump out to a one-nothing lead
3-2 pitch and that's a swing and a miss
so diaz strikes out for the first out
the wind and the 1-1 pitch and that's
lifted toward right and a play for canna
as he looks up in that unique sky stays
with it makes the cats then it goes over
but george springer with his 38th career
lead off home run gives houston a
one-nothing lead luis garcia first big
league start his big league debut came
friday in anaheim the one-two breaking
ball in the dirt did he go around yes he
did says the first base umpire quinn
walcott couldn't hold up on the breaking
ball and simeon is the first strikeout
victim of garcia two out one one and
this ball is hit in the air to right
right at reddit comes in a couple of
steps makes the catch with both hands
and it's a one two three first for luis
garcia and after one inning in oakland
astros one he's nothing tucker hitting
272 327 on bates percentage eight homers
37 rbi 3-2 fastball right through the
heart freezes tucker he's gone to
looking and lizardo to the plate and a
fastball right in there for strike three
reddick gonna looking a nice comeback
frame for lizardo three up and three
down two k's bottom of the second and
matt olsen stands in against luis garcia
this time he pulls one on the ground
correa to his left
fires to julie guriel for out number one
olson retired for the first out of the
second the o2
and grossman lines this one right at
correa and the shortstop makes the grab
for route number two hit right to him
two two to cam and that's a ground ball
hit left side to his left correa
shortstop up with it throws to first in
time and the inning is over another one
two three frame for garcia runners on
first and second one out the astros up
one nothing the two-two pitch diaz
swings and slices one down the right
field line toward the corner hustling
over as canna deep in the corner
reaching the warning track makes the
catch
tagging going to third as mayfield
springer back to first base and mark
canna had a lot of ground to cover he
was able to flag it down well no pitch
hit on the ground sharply off the glove
of the diving olson picked up by kemp to
his right underhand flips to first to
get brantley it worked out for the a's
three four three to get the out cody
kemp a 269 hitter no homers three rbis
swing and a miss luis garcia wins that
battle on a 3-2 pitch kemp goes down
swinging second strikeout for garcia
that ball hit hard but at the second
baseman diaz and garcia has three
shutout innings so far as he gets
through the a's in the third he's
looking for their first hit off the
rookie luis garcia making his first
major league start
oh yeah 94 dotted up simeon's been a
strikeout victim twice luis garcia has
three strikeouts
it's that one hard and it's gonna get
through the shift into right center so
that's the first hit for the a's the two
hits allowed by garcia in his short
career so far both been my left-handed
hitters and there's a line drive to
right but coming on josh redick puts it
away so one hit one man left on base
luis garcia first big league start
second big league appearance has allowed
one hit and one walk through four
innings striking out three 3-2 to
machine and did he go around on the
pitch downstairs he did says the third
base umpire mark ripper and machine
strikes out and that is four k's for
garcia two out first pitch and kemp
bounces it right side right at the
second baseman diaz he has it throws to
first in time in the inning is over five
innings complete of scoreless baseball
for luis garcia in his first big league
start
now at julie guriel's turn he's over two
two one
and that's hit hitting the air pretty
well and pretty deep to left center
field it sends back grossman still going
back looking up see you later
julie guriel goes deep and the astros go
up two to nothing yule guriel
hits home run number six on the season
that'll make luis garcia smile a little
bit bigger with that big last two out
home run so the a's with runners on the
corners and two outs here's the 01 to
grossman and that's a ground ball left
side deep in the hole backhanded by
correa guns it over to first on the hop
and it's in time to get grossman an
outstanding play by carlos correa in the
inning deep in the shortstops hole and a
one-hop throw to first base that will
leave it up to tommy la stella lestello
one for three tonight one strike pitch
lestella reaches for it flares it
towards shallow left racing over and in
his tucker and he goes into a slide and
he can't make the catch rolls into foul
ground near the as bullpen one run is in
around third here comes murphy he will
score and the a's have tied the game so
le stella now the winning run at second
base two outs for ramon lauriano
driven left center field
nobody's gonna get it and that's the
ball game as la stella rounds third and
heads home and ramon laureato against
his former team
walks it off and the a's have taken
three of the first four games from the
astros